THE PRESS CONFERENCE TO DO ITS
THING.
>> WE ARE MOMENTS AWAY AS WE
WANT TO GET YOU LIVE TO STAPLES
CENTER.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK IS NOW A
LAKER.
>> THIS IS AN EXCITING DAY,
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY BEING HERE
IN PERSON.
THERE ARE A FEW PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO THINK.
FIRST, I WANTED TO THANK KYLE
KUZMA, MONTREZL HARRELL, AND
K.C.P., FOR THEIR LAKER
LEGACIES.
TWO OF THOSE PLAYERS OF COURSE
ARE CHAMPIONS WITH US.
I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR
JOURNEY HERE.
I WANTED TO THANK THE WIZARDS
ORGANIZATION, TED LEONSIS, AND
THEIR GENERAL MANAGER, JUST FOR
THE SPIRIT OF COLLABORATION AND
PROFESSIONALISM IN HANDLING A
TRANSACTION THAT WAS SEEN AS A
WIN-WIN FOR BOTH FRANCHISES.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THAD FOR
SHAPE -- THAD FOUCHER FOR HIS
SPIRIT OF COOPERATION TO ONBOARD
RUSSELL WITH OUR TEAM.
I THINK TODAY IS AN INCREDIBLY
EXCITING DAY FOR THE LAKERS
ORGANIZATION.
TO BE SITTING ON THE PODIUM TO
INTRODUCE ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYMAKERS WHO HAS EVER PLAYED
IS SOMETHING WE FEEL INCREDIBLY
FORTUNATE AND BLESSED TO DO
TODAY.
WE HAD SOME GOALS THIS
OFF-SEASON AS WE WERE
TRANSITIONING INTO BUILDING OUR
TEAM.
TWO OF THE PRIMARY THINGS WE
WANTED TO ADDRESS WAS ADDING
ANOTHER PLAYMAKER AND ADDING
SHOOTING.
I THINK YOU'VE ALL SEEN THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MEET THOSE
GOALS WITH A LOT OF CONFIDENCE.
TODAY IS ABOUT THE PLAYMAKER
PIECE.
THINKING ABOUT RUSSELL
WESTBROOK, THERE IS TWO THINGS
THAT COME TO MIND FOR ME AS A
GENERAL MANAGER.
HE IS ONE OF THE MOST LIKED AND
RESPECTED IN THE LEAGUE BY
PLAYERS HE HAS PLAYED WITH.
HE IS AN INCREDIBLE LEADER.
WHEN YOU TALK TO TEAM IT'S FROM
THE OTHER STORIED FRANCHISES HE
HAS PLAYED WITH, THE YOU GET IS
HE IS ONE OF THE GREAT TEAMMATES
THEY HAVE PLAYED WITH.
THOSE ARE QUALITIES THAT ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
TEAM.
THE SECOND THING, I THINK HE IS
AN ELITE CLASS IN TERMS OF HIS
COMPETITIVE NATURE.
ONE OF THE CORE QUALITIES AS WE
BUILD A ROSTER IS SEEKING OUT
GUYS THAT HAVE A HEIGHTENED
SENSE OF BEING COMPETITIVE
WARRIORS ON THE COURT, PLAYERS
THAT PLAY WITH THE ULTIMATE SORT
OF GRIT AND GRIND AND TENACITY.
RUSSELL STANDS IN AN ELITE CLASS
IN THAT CATEGORY.
THE LAST THING I HAVE REALLY
SEEN WITH THE GROWTH OF HIS
GAME, EARLY IN OUR CAREERS, WHEN
A LOT OF US ARE YOUNG, WE SEE
THINGS A CERTAIN WAY.
A LOT OF HIS TRIPLE DOUBLES
EARLY WERE DONE WITH FORCE.
NOW I THINK THEY ARE DONE WITH
FORCE AND THOUGHTFULNESS.
HOW HE USES THE PIECES, THE
PLAYER HE PLAYS WITH, AND MAKES
THE SUM OF THE PARTS GREATER
THAN ANY INDIVIDUAL.
I THINK HE HAS REALLY LEARNED
HOW TO THINK THE GAME AT A
HIGHER LEVEL.
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE QUALITIES
THAT HAVE ATTRACTED US.
WE ARE PROUD TO INTRODUCE
RUSSELL WESTBROOK AS A LAKER
ENTITY QUESTIONS.
>> EVEN THEN, YOU YOU WANTED TO
BE A LAKER, HOW MUCH THIS DAY
MEANS TO YOU.
THE OTHER PART OF THE QUESTION,
IN THE PAST, YOU HAVE BEEN USED
TO BEING FOCAL POINT OF THE
OFFENSE.
WHAT ADJUSTMENTS WILL YOU MAKE
NOW YOUR PLAYING WITH PEOPLE
LIKE A.D. AND LEBRON?
>> FIRST, IT IS SURREAL.
I THINK IT HAS STILL NOT QUITE
HIT ME YET, BEING FROM L.A.,
GROWING UP NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE
, BEING ABLE TO WATCH THE
PARADES, TRYING TO MISS SCHOOL
TO GO TO THEM, BEING A LAKER
FAN.
NOW, EVERYTHING COMING FULL
CIRCLE FOR ME.
IT IS A BLESSING.
A LOT OF THINGS I CANNOT PUT
INTO WORDS BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
DREAMS DO NOT COME TRUE FOR
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF.
I AM TRULY BLESSED AND THANKFUL
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I CAN'T
WAIT TO GET STARTED.
SECONDLY, I HAVE BEEN BLESSED TO
BE GOING INTO MY 14TH SEASON AND
EACH YEAR, I TRY TO FIND WAYS TO
LIFT AND MAKE MY TEAMMATES
BETTER AROUND ME.
A.D. AND LEBRON ARE FRIENDS OF
MINE FIRST.
MY JOB AS A TEAMMATE IS TO COME
IN AND UPLIFT THEM.
AND THEY WILL DO THE SAME FOR
ME, VICE VERSA.
THERE WILL BE UPS AND DOWNS.
THAT IS NORMAL.
BUT WE WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PLAY, THE BEST WAY TO BE ABLE TO
WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
REPORTER: ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTER.
I WAS JUST WONDERING WHAT IT WAS
LIKE KIND OF TALKING TO LEBRON
AND 80, GETTING THAT COMFORT
LEVEL THAT YOU GUYS COULD KIND
OF WORK A CHEMISTRY AND FIT ON
AND OFF THE COURT.
HOW DID YOU GET COMFORTABLE WITH
THE IDEA THAT YOU COULD ALL PLAY
TOGETHER?
RUSSELL: HONESTLY, THIS STUFF
HAPPENS SO QUICKLY, THIS HAPPENS
SO FAST.
THE LAST TWO WEEKS OR SO.
WE HAVE HAD BRIEF CONVERSATIONS,
OBVIOUSLY HOW WE NEED TO DO IT.
WE WILL ADDRESS THAT AS TRAINING
CAMP AND THE SEASON COMES ALONG.
>> WHEN YOU WENT THROUGH THIS
PROCESS, HOW DRAINING WAS IT,
HOW TIRING WAS IT, AND HOW HAPPY
WAS YOUR FAMILY THAT YOU GOT
BACK TO L.A.?
RUSSELL: ANYTIME HE SITUATION
LIKE THIS COMES ABOUT, THEY CAN
BE STRESSFUL, AND A LOT OF
EMOTIONS.
BUT, ULTIMATELY, THE BIGGEST
THING FOR ME, BEING IN THIS
LEAGUE WENT YOU KNOW TEAMS
ACTUALLY WANT YOU, TO ME, THAT
MEANS MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
IT IS MY JOB TO MAKE SURE I COME
AND DO WHAT I AM SUPPOSED TO DO,
AND THAT IS TO COMPETE IN MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A CHANCE TO COMPETE
FOR THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND, YES, MY FAMILY WAS VERY
HAPPY.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WAY THE
LEAGUE IS SHAPING UP RIGHT NOW,
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS TEAM
STACKING UP WITH OTHER
CONTENDERS, AND HOW MEANINGFUL
IS IT FOR YOU TO BE BACK IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU COULD SAY AT
THE START OF THE YEAR, THE GOAL
IS TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP?
RUSSELL: TO BE HONEST, MY
MINDSET, I NEVER REALLY -- I CAN
ONLY CONTROL WHAT WAS IN OUR
LOCKER ROOM, HOW WE WERE ABLE TO
COMPETE, PUT OUR TEAM UP AGAINST
ANYBODY.
THAT IS JUST KIND OF HOW MY
MINDSET IS.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO PROVE?
RUSSELL: NO.
I DON'T.
I HAVE BEEN BLESSED AND THANKFUL
TO BE IN THIS LEAGUE SO LONG,
AND LUCKY TO BE ABLE TO PLAY AND
BE HEALTHY.
WHEN I GOT DRAFTED IN THE NBA,
THAT WAS ME PROVING PEOPLE
WRONG.
WHEN I WAS ABLE TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND GET A DEGREE, THAT WAS
PROVING PEOPLE WRONG.
NOT GET A DEGREE, I WISH I GOT A
DEGREE.
BUT GOING TO COLLEGE, THAT
PROVED PEOPLE WRONG.
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO LIST THE
PEOPLE AROUND ME, MY FAMILY,
BEEN ABLE TO IMPACT PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS THE WORLD WITH THIS
PLATFORM THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN TO
ME.
I WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO MAKE
SURE WE USE WHAT WE HAVE TO
IMPACT THOSE AROUND YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
HOW DO YOU INITIALLY ENVISIONED
HOW YOU AND LEBRON WILL SHARE
BALLHANDLING, PLAYMAKING?
RUSSELL: AS YOU KNOW, LEBRON IS
ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS TO PLAY
THIS GAME.
HIS ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO KIND
OF DO EVERYTHING ON THE FLOOR
ALLOWS ME TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
IT OUT.
I AM COMING TO A
CHAMPIONSHIP-CALIBER TEAM AND MY
JOB IS TO MAKE SURE I MAKE HIS
GAME EASY FOR HIM.
AS IT PERTAINS TO BALLHANDLING
AND ALL OF THAT, IT REALLY DOES
NOT MATTER.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS YOU CAN
IMPACT THE GAME WITHOUT HAVING
THE BALL IN YOUR HANDS.
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT FOR
YEARS.
WE WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
REPORTER: I KNEW YOU GREW UP IN
L.A., WATCHING THE LAKERS.
HE ALSO HAD A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH KOBE BRYANT.
DID YOU HAVE THAT IN YOUR HEAD
AT ALL WHEN THIS TRADE WAS
COMING TOGETHER?
RUSSELL: IT HAS NOT LEFT MY
HEAD.
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT, ME AND HIM, JUST THE
POTENTIAL OF ME BEING ABLE TO BE
A LAKER, UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
ENTAILS.
IT IS JUST CRAZY TO THINK ABOUT.
EVERY TIME I HAVE PUT THAT LAKER
JERSEY ON, AND THAT IS ALL I CAN
SAY ABOUT THAT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO START OFF
WITH MIKE.
REPORTER: WELCOME TO LOS
ANGELES.
JUST TO FOLLOW-UP ON KOBE, THERE
WAS THAT TIME DURING HIS LAST
YEAR WHEN HE CAME TO OKLAHOMA
CITY AND YOU AND KD HAD SOME
TIME WITH HIM IN THE LOCKER ROOM
TO EXCHANGE GIFTS.
THE WHOLE MENTALITY WHEN HE USED
TO TALK ABOUT YOU, SOMETHING
THAT ROB ALLUDED TO, THE
CONSTANT COMPETITIVE FIRE.
WAS THAT SOMETHING THAT CAME
FROM COMPETITION, PLAYING
AGAINST HIM AND TALKING TO HIM?
RUSSELL: I THINK THAT WAS THE
INITIAL THING THAT KIND OF
PRODUCT TOGETHER, BEING ABLE TO
COMPETE, NOT BEING ABLE TO TAKE
NIGHTS OFF.
WE BEGAN HAVING A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP OFF THE FLOOR AS
BROTHERS.
THINGS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO
WITH THIS GAME.
TO ME, THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING I HAVE CHERISH
FROM KOBE THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO CHERISH.
>> I REMEMBER, THE YEAR THAT
RUSSELL DID THE -- BROKE THE
RECORD THAT NO ONE THOUGHT WOULD
EVER BE BROKEN IN TERMS OF
AVERAGING A TRIPLE-DOUBLE AND
PUTTING HIMSELF IN THE CATEGORY
OF PLAYERS LIKE THE BIG O.
THERE WERE A SMALL HANDFUL OF
PLAYERS AROUND THE NBA THAT KOBE
REALLY FELT LIKE EMBODIED THAT
MAMBA MENTALITY.
I REMEMBER THROUGHOUT THAT YEAR,
JUST HIS PRAISE FOR RUSSELL'S
APPROACH, HIM TALKING ABOUT THAT
COMPETITIVE EDGE THAT IS RARE IN
SPORTS.
I CAN JUST HEAR HIM SAYING, HE
GETS IT.
HE HAS GOT IT.
>> OUR NEXT QUESTION WILL BE
FROM DAVE, ESPN.
>> ALL-STAR WITH RUSS AND I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR ROB AS WELL.
RUSS, YOU HAVE HAD SO MANY
MOMENTS IN YOUR CAREER, WHETHER
IT BE THAT FIRST ROUND SERIES
WITH THE LAKERS, THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH KOBE COMEDY
NIPSEY HOUSEL PLAYOFF GAME.
MELLO TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
LAKERS ALWAYS SEEMED TO BE ON
HIS RADAR TO SOME EXTENT.
I WONDER IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
THAT AND DID YOU SHARE THE TYPE
OF SENTIMENT LIKE THAT?
RUSSELL: AT SOME POINT,
OBVIOUSLY BEING FROM L.A., YOU
ALWAYS WISH THAT YOU CAN PLAY
FOR YOUR HOME TEAM.
THAT IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT ALWAYS KIND OF CIRCLED
AROUND IN MY MIND, MAYBE ONE
DAY.
I WOULD ALWAYS COME BACK, THAT
PROBABLY WON'T HAPPEN.
BUT NOW WE ARE HERE AND I WILL
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE.
>> FOR ROB, LAST YEAR, THE TEAM
CERTAINLY WAS DECIMATED BY
INJURIES AND THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN THE DIRECTION YOU KIND OF
CAME TO A CONCLUSION ON, IF WE
HAD HEALTH, WE CAN RUN IT BACK.
WHAT MOTIVATED YOU TO MAKE SUCH
DRAMATIC CHANGES?
ROB: OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK IT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE AN AGGRESSIVE MOVE THAT WE
FELT LIKE BETTERED OUR
PROBABILITY TO BRING THE 18TH
TITLE TO THE LAKERS.
WHEN AN OPPORTUNITY LIKE THAT
COMES, YOU ARE THOUGHTFUL, YOU
ANALYZE IT, YOU LOOK AT THE PROS
AND CONS, AND YOU MAKE A
DECISION.
WE FELT LIKE THIS WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAXIMIZE OUR
ABILITY TO DO WHAT WE ARE
ASSESSED TO DO, BRING AN 18TH
TITLE TO THE CITY.
>> I WILL THROW IT BACK TO YOU
GUYS.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> RUSSELL, YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ADAMANT ABOUT HOW CHALLENGERS
AND BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
DEVELOPED YOU WERE AS A YOUNG
MAN.
NOW YOU GET TO COME HOME AND BE
A ROLE MODEL FOR THE YOUNG BOYS
AND GIRLS WHO ARE NOW WHERE YOU
ONCE WERE.
RUSSELL: THAT IS KIND OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT BEING
BACK HOME, BEING ABLE TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH,
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN THE
CITY OF L.A.
MY FOCUS WILL BE IN THE
COMMUNITY LIKE IT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AND CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS
TO UPLIFT OUR COMMUNITIES AS
MUCH AS I CAN.
REPORTER: WELCOME BACK.
YOU HAVE SO MANY TITLES TO BE
PROUD OF.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE BIGGEST
THING YOU HAVE TO OFFER TO THE
LAKERS.
AND THAT JUST FOR FUN WHAT ARE
YOU MOST LOOKING FORWARD TO OFF
THE COURT TO BEING BACK HOME?
RUSSELL: ONE THING I ALWAYS HAVE
DONE AND WILL DO IS STAY TRUE TO
MYSELF.
I CAN NEVER WAIVER IN THIS
LEAGUE.
I ALWAYS WANT TO STAY TRUE TO
WHO I AM AND WITH THAT, MAKING
SURE I AM ABLE TO LISTEN, BE ALL
EARS.
BECAUSE I AM COMING TO AN
UNBELIEVABLE ORGANIZATION, TEAM,
PLAYERS I AM ABLE TO LEARN FROM.
FIND THINGS I AM ABLE TO LEARN
TO BE ABLE TO IMPROVE MY GAME
AND BE A BETTER PLAYER.
BACK HOME, JUST BEING ABLE TO BE
WITH MY KIDS ALL THE TIME, THE
ABLE TO SEE MY MOM AND DAD, MY
WIFE ALL THE TIME, TO ME IT'S
THE BEST THING I CAN ASK FOR,
NOT HAVING TO TRAVEL EVERYWHERE
IS A BLESSING FOR ME.
REPORTER: A LOT OF THE NEW --
TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY WERE
EXCITED TO PLAY WITH YOU.
I WANTED TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE ROSTER, A COMBINATION OF
VETERANS, OBVIOUSLY LEBRON.
RUSSELL: THE ROSTER IS GREAT.
A LOT OF GUYS I HAVE ALREADY
KNOWN PREVIOUSLY, WHICH IS EVEN
BETTER.
LIKE I SAID BEFORE, AS I COME
INTO THE SEASON, I AM ALWAYS
LOOKING AT THE ROSTER FIGURING
OUT HOW I CAN MAKE OTHER GUYS
BETTER.
IT IS AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
I WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW I AM
ABLE TO LEAVE AN IMPACT ON
PEOPLE.
I AM REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING TOGETHER WITH ALL THE
GUYS, FIGURING OUT.
REPORTER: QUESTION FOR FRANK.
RUSS KIND OF SHARED A LITTLE BIT
OF HIS VISION OF HOW THIS COULD
WORK OUT OVERTIME.
WHAT IS YOUR VISION FOR HOW
LEBRON, 80, AND RUSSELL CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER.
FRANK: I THINK ANYTIME YOU HAVE
THREE GREAT PLAYERS LIKE THIS,
THERE IS AN ELEMENT OF SACRIFICE
REQUIRED.
WE HAVE ALL TALKED ABOUT THAT.
BUT, THESE THREE GUYS CAN DO IT
ALL.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT OUR GROUP IS
THERE ALL MAKE THE RIGHT PLAY
PLAYERS.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT SCORING OR
BEING A ONE-DIMENSIONAL PLAYER.
THEY CAN ALL DO IT ALL.
I AM MOST EXCITED ABOUT SEEING
WHAT THE THREE OF THEM ON THE
COURT AT THE SAME TIME LOOKS
LIKE.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO BE AN
EXTREMELY DYNAMIC, FAST BREAKING
TEAM, AND ONE THAT CAN PLAY OFF
THE BALL THREE GUYS IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
I THINK WITH THE ATHLETICISM OF
THOSE GUYS, PLUS THE COMPLEMENT
REPORTS WE PUT TOGETHER, THE
SHOOTERS AND DEFENDERS, I THINK
WE HAVE GOT A REAL CHANCE THIS
YEAR TO DO SOMETHING SPECIAL.
IT IS ON US NOW TO PUT IN THE
WORK, GET THESE TYPE OF TALENTED
GUYS TO BUY IN AND PUT IN THE
WORK.
HOPEFULLY, WE CAN ACHIEVE
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
>> MUCH HAS BEEN MADE ABOUT THE
AGE OF THIS ROSTER.
COULD THAT ACTUALLY BE A WEAPON,
SOMETHING TO YOUR ADVANTAGE?
WHEN WE CONSIDER THAT AGE EQUALS
EXPERIENCE.
>> AGE DOES EQUAL EXPERIENCE IQ,
INTELLIGENCE HELPS YOU WIN.
IN TERMS OF MOTIVATION, THE
MOTIVATION FOR US IS THAT
TROPHY.
THIS GROUP IS HIGHLY DRIVEN TO
GET BACK ON TOP.
I DON'T REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
ANYBODY IS SAYING ABOUT OUR AGE
BUT I DO AGREE THAT THE
EXPERIENCE WILL BE NECESSARY AND
WILL HELP US WIN.
REPORTER: RUSS, I WAS JUST
WONDERING, YOU HAD SO MUCH
STABILITY IN OKLAHOMA CITY, THAT
YOU PLAYED FOR A COUPLE OF TEAMS
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
DOES THAT CHANGE YOUR CONCEPT OF
WHAT YOU WANT OUT OF A
FRANCHISE.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE ARE FACTORS
BEYOND ANY ONE PERSON'S CONTROL.
IS YOUR VISION TO BE WITH THE
LAKERS FOR A LONG TIME?
RUSSELL: YOU UNDERSTAND, THIS IS
A BUSINESS.
THROUGH THAT, YOU JUST DO YOUR
JOB.
THAT IS WHAT I WILL CONTINUE TO
DO.
AS FAR AS THE BUSINESS SIDE OF
BASKETBALL, FIGURING OUT WHERE I
WILL BE, I COULD NOT HAVE
IMAGINED I WOULD BE HERE 3, 4
YEARS AGO.
BUT, WHILE I AM HERE, I WILL
PLAY THE BEST WAY I KNOW HOW,
GIVE EVERYTHING I HAVE.
I WILL LET THE BUSINESS SIDE OF
BASKETBALL TAKE CARE OF THAT.
>> I WANT TO THANK RUSSELL'S
FAMILY AND SUPPORT TEAM THAT IS
HERE TODAY.
WHEN I WAS AN AGENT FOR JAMES
HARDEN, I WENT TO A LOT OF
THUNDER GAMES EARLY IN HIS
CAREER.
RUSSELL'S DAD WILL BE A PERFECT
PART OF LAKER NATION WITH THE
ENERGY HE BRINGS.
>> IT IS OFFICIAL, IF YOU WILL.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK, A LOS ANGELES
LAKERS.
YOU LIKE THAT?
>> I DO.
FOR ME, HAVING PLAYED IN THE
1980'S, AND TO SEE HOW THE
LEAGUE HAS EVOLVED, PLAYERS
TRYING TO CONNECT, COLLABORATE
EVEN, TRYING TO WIN
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
YOU SEE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
BROOKLYN, GOLDEN STATE A FEW
YEARS AGO.
THAT IS COOL.
THAT IS NOW.
AND TO HAVE RUSSELL WESTBROOK,
AT THIS POINT IN HIS CAREE